you know when covid first showed up
I loved listening to the commentaries
the number of people who said in these
uncertain times
and I would always giggle to myself
because all times are uncertain
there's never been a time in history
that wasn't uncertain
um all that happened was something that
we didn't expect happened suddenly that
reminded us
you know that things are uncertain every
stock market crashed nobody knew that
was going to happen tomorrow it's always
uncertain and this is where a finite
Minds an infinite mindset rather this is
where an infinite mindset could be very
valuable
because players who play with a finite
mindset
fear uncertainty and work hard to avoid
surprise which is why they like short
time frames we like the quarter or most
the year don't talk to me about three
years or five years that that freaks me
out and I like everything to go
according to plan and be very
predictable and so when something
unexpected happens Panic is their normal
reaction right
when you learn
when we learn to embrace an infinite
mindset
we actually see opportunity in Surprise
and we Embrace uncertainty
so when something unexpected happens
it's still stressful
but when something unexpected happens we
go oh I wonder what we can do with this
this is exciting hey team come here
let's talk about how do we work in these
in these in this environment
and I saw it happen during covet it was
so easy to see which companies were
playing with a finite mindset in which
you're playing with an infinite mindset
because the finite minded companies
panicked
and went into survival mode and
everything was about themselves how are
we gonna survive how are we gonna make
money
right whereas the ones with the infinite
mindset went okay opportunity here what
if we were to start our company from
scratch today how would we do things
like what if we didn't exist yesterday
and today was the first day of work how
would we do things still very stressful
but very exciting and instead of putting
themselves at the center they were very
more preoccupied with the customer
people still want what we have how do we
get it to them as opposed to how can we
make money
and so I could tell the difference
immediately and so the more we learn to
embrace an infinite mindset uncertainty
becomes a joy becomes an opportunity for
creativity
and so it's that's one of the huge
benefits